let's list all listen to Nicholas V I've
got an idea
no police come on Nick
no name Feliz government handle your own
I run their own block do you want you
don't like the bright brother killem
let's do the Nancy Grace approach to the
courtroom when charged you will appear
in court on the date specified and you
will be shocked no trial
save a lot of money so you're in favor
of Ferguson style policing because that
works out so well no I'm all right yeah
we are you saying that the police no II
think when the Miley's Larry my ability
of the Ferguson style yeah the blacks
would control all the neighborhoods all
right so that sounds pretty libertarian
they have early police or really don't
know local name whatever manner you want
okay you can wear whatever uniform you
all right if you if you want that's a
libertarian or just constantly bringing
about sex and nudity you're 81 years old
you are on your eighth marriage right
across seven women eight marriages come
on
okay bye oh you know just you you must
be doing something right let me ask you
this insanely as shown it is it's
bleeding I'm dirt